thank you
thank you good afternoon and welcome to
this northwestern area planning
committee meeting
on wednesday the 26th of august 2020. my
name is councilman maddie thompson and
i'm the chairman of this committee
this meeting is being held under
regulations which came into effect on
4th of april
in response to the covid19 pandemic
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in the meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted and your video
feed off when you're not addressing the
committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded and be
sorry by being present in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
and i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
members when speaking and referring to
agenda papers please reference a page or
paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
and video if possible now if i may ask
officers taking part in the meeting
to introduce themselves starting with mr
lee mr lee
good afternoon chairman i am matthew lee
and i am lead specialist place at morgan
district council
thank you thank you next on my list is
mr johnson
good afternoon chair my name is michael
johnson i am development management
lead specialist thank you thank you
and i believe you'll be reading out the
submissions from
um that are made by applicants and
objectives and so on
yes i will chairman thank you excellent
thank you just checking
uh right next we have ms parker haynes
good afternoon i'm hayley parker-haynes
and i am a senior caseworker in
development management here at morden
district council
thank you and miss bowles
good afternoon my name is hannah i am a
specialist in development management
thank you thank you and miss bird
good afternoon i'm tara bird i'm the
committee clock for this meeting thank
you chairman
thank you are there any other officers
present who are taking part in this
meeting as as opposed to supporting us
through the it
i'll take that as a no tara could you
please carry out a roll call of members
to confirm who's in attendance thank you
oh yes chairman members i'll call your
names alphabetically if you could just
confirm if you're here please
i'm councillor bamford yes i'm here tara
good afternoon
councillor durham
present thank you councillor jarvis
presenter
[Music]
good afternoon tara present thank you
and councilman mrs thompson
obviously you're presently um
yes present thank you excellent thank
you
um are there any other members in
attendance could they please introduce
themselves
good afternoon and welcome to chrissy
morris
thank you councillor morris anybody else
can't see anybody else no
thank you right apologies for absence
item number
two on the agenda may i have apologies
for abstinence please miss bird
oh yes chairman apologies have been
received from councillor
mrs fleming and councillor morley thank
you
thank you item three is the minutes of
the 29th of july
the recommended that the minutes be
approved as a true and accurate record
you can find them on pages
7 to 12. members may i please take them
as read rather than ascent i'm going to
ask for dissent so if if you have
anything to raise about the minutes
please let me know
have you all had time to read them if
you haven't please let me know
if there are any masters of accuracy can
you please let me know
okay in that case i'm going to put the
recommender i'm going to put a
recommendation that we do accept them
as um a record of the meeting
that's fine chairman okay everybody else
happy if you're not happy please tell it
to say so now
brilliant thank you
uh okay we don't have any other members
wishing to
speak we've done the vote so
declarations of interest
item four i have to read this to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph six to
eight inclusive of the code of conduct
for members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise through the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function
now to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
i have a hand up from councillor white
um councillor white i've also got
councillor durham um
well i'll go ladies first since i spot
at the hand first if i'm not
counseling sorry i'm sorry yeah sorry
for that chairman um
on the first agenda on the item which is
oakfield farm i'm
going to declare an interest um purely
because last time his planning
application got turned down
at uh under delegated powers um he got
very upset with john and myself
i will participate in the discussion but
i will not take a vote on it
okay thank you very much councillor
darren please
thank you chairman um can you hear me
i can thank you oh thank you very much a
non-punary interest chairman
as a member of essex county council who
are statutory consultees in a variety of
matters pertaining to planning thank you
thank you very much okay members item
five the first step planning application
we're looking at which is oakfield farm
hi chase pearly yeah
the details can be found on pages 13-28
um sorry i've just spotted an email
pop-up
i will call on the officer in a moment
to present this item
and members just a reminder if you wish
to speak please don't make this known by
using the chat function
and i will come to you in turn uh so ms
parker haynes could you
present the report please
thank you chairman planning permission
is sought for the demolition of the
existing barn on site and the
replacement with a three-bedroom
dwelling
the site currently has a lawful b1 use
this is the location plan so the
existing barn is here and the proposed
replacement
dwelling would be here this is the block
plan
these are closed elevations
sorry chairman for clarity i'm not
seeing anything as if
is everybody else oh okay well asked i
actually can
um i think i can see everything that's
fine
that's fine as long as the members okay
as long as you can feel the other ones
relevant for the debate that's fine just
um i wasn't getting anything okay it's
great
okay if anyone else could you indicate
if you haven't most people are
indicating yes but i don't want to leave
anyone out
you can always have the slides emailed
to you
okay thank you sorry about that mr lee
let's let's carry on if you're all right
with not seeing it
thank you these are the floor and roof
plans
the elevations of the existing barn
and photographs of the site from hide
chase
in 2014 an outline application with all
matters reserved was submitted for the
construction of a new dwelling and
double garage alongside the demolition
of the barn
the dwelling the subject of this
application was to be located in the
same place as the barn
this application was refused and
subsequently dismissed it appeal due to
the harmful effect
the development would have on the
character and appearance of the area
and that the site would not meet the
sustainable transport aims of the mppf
the dwelling proposed by this current
application is to be set closer to the
boundary with hyde chase
this application is recommended for
refusal as the site lies outside of the
defined settlement boundary of pearly
where policies of restraint apply
the proposed development is poorly
located relative to facilities services
and sustainable modes of transport
furthermore the proposed development
would result in the loss of an
employment use whereby it has not been
demonstrated that there is no demand
the proposal would also substantially
alter the character and intrinsic beauty
of the countryside
finally insufficient information has
been provided to show that the
development would not have
have an unacceptable impact in terms of
ecology
it is not considered that there are any
new material considerations that would
support the application to such a degree
as to outward
outweigh the previous inspector's
decision thank you chairman
thank you thank you very much uh right
the recommendation is set up within the
report is as follows the planning
application
twenty zero zero four seven two oak
field farm
be refused for the reasons as detailed
in the report
i put that before you i've got
councillor durham waiting to speak but
members are going to put
that before you this actually doesn't
require a second but i'm going to ask
for one so i have an idea
um that at least you know at least where
we're going
so councillor dara
councillor bamford well i'll just say
i'm going to second the proposal
for the recommendation thank you very
much councillor darren well
i'll i'll third it then um i i totally
agree i think the officers have this one
absolutely uh
absolutely right there's no significant
change from the previously refused
and the previously refused appeal so um
yeah i sincerely hope that this is
refused thank you
thank you well i'm going to go first
actually to councillor
wyatt as she's the only board member we
have present if you'd like to go
next councillor white please do at the
end thank you
just to echo what my previous council
has said in relation to the previous um
planning history but as i say i won't
take a vote on this but thank you very
much
thank you um councillor bamford i have
you down to speak is that
yeah nice thank you very much i know i
know i
seconded the proposal i just want to ask
a question of the officers
because in the conclusion on page 15
it does mention uh policy t1
um as sustainable transport which is
part of the conclusion but t1 is not
mentioned
in the uh reasons for refusal so i just
wondered why that was
why that policy has not been included
thank you um i think i know the answer
but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna risk misleading anyone so
um
miss um parker haynes or mr johnson or
mr lee please
hello i'm just a little thank you by the
looks of it um
the chairman yeah um i will take you to
exactly the wording
of policy t1 if you just
um that's around sustainable transport
and particularly aimed at the
strategic sites and looking at new
larger forms of infrastructure to
support that so
while that is the ball brush stroke when
you're actually drilling to the
specifics for the reason for refusal it
is just
specifically in relation to the impacts
of accessibility of this site which is
policy t2
thank you chairman okay and i
my my thought was that the report does
actually form
part of the decision and therefore it's
available to anyone who needs it is that
right tell me please if i'm not
do you chairman if the application is
refused obviously that would form part
of our
part basis yeah that's correct thank you
thank you very much
okay members anyone else to speak does
that answer your questions
counselor bamford
did you want to come back at all well
yes partly but
i mean t2 isn't included in the refusal
either
but as you say if the report is taken
into account appeal then i suppose we've
covered ourselves
um but i just wondered why that wasn't
included that's fine thank you
thank you very much okay members i don't
have anyone else to speak um
so you chairman if members want we can
add that for reason few to the reason
for you so that's fine
um members wish i'll have to add that to
the recommendation
as everybody else so just to clarify
madam chair we're adding t2
to the reason the policy for reason of a
refusal
is that correct yes is that
is that correct mr lee
mr lee give me two seconds sorry
chairman i'm just gonna get down to read
the
actual one right okay
well so thank you chairman actually
reading the
report obviously
reason for refusal to while i'm looking
at the agenda is in relation to the
essex coast recreation
so it wouldn't form an issue in relation
to that reason for refusal
i got that um
it would be it would be reason for you
to one
that t2 should be added to i would have
thought
are we confusing our ones and our twos
did you mean to the policy not not
reason to
i i think madam chairman we just leave
it as it is it's fine
thank you that certainly makes things
simple thank you
uh some members i prefer i propose to go
to a
vote um i think we will have a roll call
please thank
um miss bird if you could go go through
a roll call
thank you chairman members i'll call
your names alphabetically if you could
just
indicate if you're for against or
abstaining please
starting with councillor bamford please
four
thank you councillor darum four
thank you councillor jarvis
four thank you councillor keys
four
thank you councillor mrs thompson four
thank you and councillor miss white
um stay in because i'm not taking a part
in this vote thank you
thank you very much so that is
four six four nobody against and one
abstention thank you
thank you very much okay so that
um that item is refused in line with the
officer's recommendation and
according to the recommendation so item
six
is our next planning application of
navoli farm pump lane pearly if i've
pronounced that correctly
uh that's found on pages 29-46 there is
a members update in relation to this
application
that has been circulated and you'll be
able to find it on mod.gov
in a moment i'll call on the offices to
officer to prevent present the item
members are just reminder if you wish to
speak please let me know on the chat
function and i will come to you in turn
right miss bowles can you please present
the report
thank you chair i'm so planning
permission is sought for the demolition
of the existing outbuildings and
construction of six dwellings comprising
two terraces of three dwellings with
associated landscaping and access works
and before i begin the presentation i
just want to clarify
that the details contained within
paragraph 5.1.3 of the office's report
do not relate to this application so
please accept my apologies for the error
and any confusion
that may have caused um
sorry might ask for sorry to interrupt
but is that the
reason for the update is there anything
else covered that you
feel you should mention in the update no
that's
that's the only app today i've got thank
you very much sorry sorry
please hurry up thank you and so we here
we have the location plan
and we've got the block plan and as you
can see the two row of
three dwellings facing each other um and
the existing dwellings which are
just here have been incorporated into
the scheme and
a garage is proposed to serve each of
those dwellings
got the existing elevation and floor
plans of the
buildings currently on site says
building one and two
three and four and five and six
and all of these buildings are proposed
to be demolished
proposed elevations as you can see
there's undercroft parking
at the front here and flat roof elements
to the rear which accommodate the
parking area
and ground floor accommodation
and the roof plan this element here is
the the flat roof
we've got photos of the site
and the area to the front of the site
[Music]
so the application site lies outside of
the defined settlement boundaries where
policies of restraint apply
the proposed development was
substantially all to the character of
the site and surrounding area
and have an unacceptable visual impact
on the countryside through the
urbanization and domestication of the
site
the harm is exacerbated by the design
layout and density of the proposed
development which is in stark contrast
existing development within the
surrounding area therefore the
application is recommended for refusal
thank you chair thank you very much mrs
bubbles
right under the council's public
participation scheme we have received
one submission from the applicant
in line with the scheme i have reviewed
the submission and an officer
mr johnson will now read this out
allocating two minutes only for the
reading of the submission
um i'll just interject whereas i'm
normally very very strict on the two
minutes i appreciate
different people read at different
speeds and and my belief is that this
certainly
can be read in two minutes even if we
don't quite manage it so
mr johnson please
thank you chairman submission from
anthony
allen the applicant my name is anthony i
am the applicant and i wanted to
personally address members today
as you would have noted from the
pictures the site comprises a number of
old and tired buildings
in my opinion these buildings are of no
architectural merit
are costing a lot to maintain and do not
positively contribute to the countryside
i am looking to replace these buildings
with six two bed
houses that i feel match the pattern set
by the neighboring homes
these homes would be starter homes to
assist young families within pearly
to purchase a property in the area they
live thereby getting them into
onto the housing ladder members would
have also noted from the officers report
that
in summary the officer level objection
to the proposed development
relates to the site's location within
the countryside
loss of equity in use and that
alternative uses
haven't been discussed the case
officer's reasons for refusal does not
relate to harm to neighboring immunity
parking or highway matters flooding etc
i know members will be aware of this
however
the site does benefit from planning
permission for a residential dwelling
at which time consideration of
alternative uses was made
and the council accepted alternative
uses not being viable
my house and its land is partially
located within the defined settlement
boundary
all the buildings are used for equine
use and therefore can be rightly
considered previously developed land
which national policy supports it is
disappointing to note that the case
officer has dismissed the benefits
of providing two-bedroom homes as part
of the scheme
i note they state the authority has a
five-year housing land supply
i also note they believe this will
deliver the large shortfall in
two-bedroom homes
however given that the local plan has
been in place since 2017
and there is still a large shortfall of
these types of property this seems
unrealistic
i would like to draw members attention
to the many letters of support submitted
by residents and they have
noted that they would prefer to see a
sensitive residential scheme
rather than existing lawful use and
buildings to remain i would also like to
highlight that national planning policy
does not seek to apply blanket
protection to the countryside
with protection been a term now only
apply to designated areas
and other valued landscapes which which
which my site does not fall within the
mere fact that part of the application
site lies outside of very defined
settlement boundary does not therefore
automatically render the site unsuitable
or that it causes harm to the area the
proposed dwellings have been designed to
be in keeping with dwellings in
and around the area being of essex
vernacular
i am sure members would have noted in
the press the government's views
and approach to reviving the economy i'd
like to stress that the economic
benefits arising from the scheme
including temporary employment during
the construction and additional spending
within the village
as well as tax receipts for the parish
district council
also worth noting in these current
difficult economic times
finally i'd like to highlight that from
the outset of the scheme
i notified the case officer i was
willing to make the rams payment
and the lack of a legal agreement to
secure rammus payment has not been
raised as an issue during the
determination of the application
and this could have been easily overcome
i can confirm that
should members be in support of this
scheme the relevant payment will be made
prior to the issuing of a decision
i genuinely believe this is a positive
application not only because the local
community support the scheme
and that it would support the local
economy but because it would positively
contribute towards the landscape
character of the area
and residential immunity we hope that
members can see the many benefits of the
proposal
thank you for your consideration thank
you chairman thank you
thank you mr johnson uh right
and do any other officers need to speak
before i move the recommendation
okay that is the planning application
um 2486 navoli farm pearly be refused
for the reasons as detailed in
section 8 of this report and and again
it doesn't require
a seconder but it would be always nice
to have one
members anyone prepared to second
yes i'm i'm happy to second that
thank you councillor-wide okay um well
you're the board member would you like
to start us off
um yes thank you i mean i have to say
the current approved application for one
larger house i'm really happy with
um and it's not the planning approval
that's the problem um
so much as the design just doesn't work
you know the i think it's
incorrect to say that the area's got
lots of terraced houses
it's got lots of nice big detached
houses
and the application that has approval
actually meets with um with what's in
the area
um and i think that he's just cramped
and i think he is out of keeping in the
area and although we need two bedroom
houses this application
is just going to be an eyesore i know i
know the buildings i know what they look
like
but this is not the best use of land um
it's not the best design
and and although i had a lot of less of
support i had a lot of letters of
objection as well
and it is the design that came up more
than anything else so i agree with the
officer's recommendation
thank you very much uh i have counselor
durham i've lost my place on the chat
i'm afraid so i think i have counsellor
durham do i have anyone else
no chairman just counselor durham has
indicated
yeah thank you very much uh um i agree
with councillor white and i agree with
the officers i
i certainly can't um disagree with the
applicant's comments that there's little
architectural merit in what is there now
um but that in my opinion doesn't
overcome the divergence to the ldp nor
does it overcome
the the cramped and out of keeping
nature of the proposed uh dwellings and
and i really you know think that once
again the officers done a good job
and uh have summed up adequate reasons
why this should be refused thank you
thank you i don't have anyone else on my
list does anyone have anything
particular they'd like to add or does
anyone wish to speak against
uh councillor jarvis i think that is
thank you yeah
madam chairman i do apologize because i
seem to be having a bit of a technical
issue
um so jumping in i just wanted to say i
just wanted to ask
uh i could see the lessons to support
regarding sort of two-bedroomed
accommodation and it's that sort of
principle of the fact that uh permission
has been given already for a property um
if there is indeed a demand for
uh two-bedroom properties in the area um
i just wanted has some research could
the officers comment on that i mean is
that true
and that there is a big demand for two
bedroom properties in the area
because if in principle it is um
uh putting the design uh of these
particular properties to one side it
will be difficult not to
find some agreement with the principle
of putting up
two-bedroom properties as opposed to a
large property and i just wanted to uh
debate that particular point madam
chairman
thank you mr lee thank you chairman um
the how or the strategic housing needs
assessment that forms the basis of the
ldp highlights that there is a shortfall
in two bed and one bed properties within
the district and
that's why our policy on the allocated
side example is bringing forward 60
on smaller properties um so there is a
there is a shortfall but that wouldn't
the ldp is designed to meet that demand
that's
the point of the policies so right
providing
additional properties conflicting with
the ldp i don't think would be
way in favor of this particularly
especially as you said it's one large
property being replaced by a number
of small properties that would all
create needs for cars on a day-to-day
basis all require
further levels of paraphernalia so the
urbanization would be exponentially
larger
and the harm from it being in this sort
of location would also be greater
so i professionally i don't think that i
understand the point you're coming from
but the weight that we should be giving
is very small in this instance i would
say thank you
thank you obviously thank you madam
chairman
thank you uh councillor bamford
please
i know it takes you a moment to unmute
i'm sure you're coming
all right sorry chairman i i i know that
i appreciate the difficulties
function i'm sorry about that chairman
um yes i
i just wanted to uh second your the
recommendation
and to emphasize that although the
applicant
um stated in the in the report that
um that michael read out that there was
a lot of local support
i note from the offices report that the
parish council
has objected um so
i can't see that there can be that much
of a
um support for you know it's not a foot
it's not everyone in the local area
that's supporting this is what i'm
saying
which seemed to come across in that
applicant's
uh report that was read out by michael
which doesn't seem to be the case
so i am as i said seconding your the
recommendation thank you
thank you uh right i have councillor
white if there's no one else i'll just
ask councillor white to
sum up for us please yeah thank you
yeah absolutely it's creating a terrace
of houses
of effectively townhouses in the
countryside and
i had letters of objection as well as
letters of approval it wasn't just one
way
um it was split about 50 50. so and i
agree with the officer's recommendation
oops
oops thank you
yeah thank you right and let's have
anyone else to speak i haven't been
notified of that miss bird could we just
have a roll call and a vote please this
is
on the officer's recommendation to
refuse
as it's written in the report thank you
oh yes chairman of course i remember
as before if you could just indicate
four against or abstain please
i'm starting with councillor bamford
please four
thank you councillor durham four thank
you very much
councillor jarvis paul thank you
councillor keys four thank you
councillor
four thank you mrs thompson
four and councillor miss white
four thank you very much the results
that are is
seven 747164 that thank you
okay thank you so that application is
refused in line with the officer's
recommendation
uh so now we have item seven it's our
third and final planning application
it's the bungalow green lane little
totten twenty six zero one
um there is a members update in relation
to this you can find them
the main part of the report on pages
47-60
in a moment i will call the officer to
present this item
um usual reminders about using the chat
function thank you very much
miss parker haynes if you present the
report please
thank you chairman planning permission
is sought for the internal refurbishment
of a building and the change of use of
land to residential
the external refurbishment of the
building started in 2009 and was
completed in 2010
and is claimed to have been used for
storage since then
advice was sought from the local
planning authority in 2009 prior to the
refurbishment
whereby it was advised as the building
had not been occupied since 1980
that it was in a state of disrepair
uninhabitable and not liable for council
tax that it was considered that the
residential use
had been abandoned this is the location
plan
this is the block plan
these are the um proposed elevations as
there are no external changes proposed
as part of this application
closed floor plan and roof plan
the existing floor and roof plan
photographs the site
as mentioned previously it is considered
that the residential use of the site has
been abandoned
in relation to abandonment case law
provides for determining factors
the physical condition of the building
the length of the period of non-use as a
dwelling
whether or not there had been any
intervening use evidence of the owner's
intention throughout the period of
non-use
whilst the supporting statement claims
that the building has been used for
storage since 2010
it is not considered that this would be
substantive in the claim that the
building has been
actively used as an independent
residential unit
this is similar in nature to the
position that the council came to at the
time of the last application
earlier in the year as no further
argument has been submitted it is not
considered that there is any reason for
the council to come to a different
conclusion
at this time this application is
recommended for refusal as the site lies
outside of the defined settlement
boundary of little tottenham where
policies of restraint apply
the proposed development is poorly
located relative to facilities services
and sustainable modes of transport
and therefore any future occupiers would
be heavily reliant on the use of the
private motor vehicle
furthermore the proposal would also
substantially alter the character and
interesting beauty of the countryside
and would detract from the open
character and nature of the site as a
result of the domestication of the site
and inclusion
of associated residential paraphernalia
thank you
thank you very much again under the
council's public participation
scheme we've received a submission from
the applicant
we've reviewed the submission and an
officer mr
johnson will read out this allocating
again the two minutes for the
reading um mr johnson please if you're
ready off you go
thank you chairman submission from
thomas
luke whitney the applicant dear
committee members
having read the case officer's report we
would like to bring the following points
for consideration
with regard to the settlement boundary
the bungalow was occupied when the
envelope was created
we have seen the boundary being moved to
accommodate other applications in recent
years
including in spaces that were not
previously residential
although the council can show a
five-year housing plan
there are no affordable properties in
little totem
the reason that we have chosen to submit
this application
is because we wish to live closer to my
parents
their property is also in green lane and
is a registered small holding
as they advance in years they will
require help maintaining the land
i grew up in little tottenham and wished
to stay permanently and contribute to
the community
the report states that the application
could spoil the look of the countryside
but the building would remain the same
externally
and we are not seeking a change for the
current footprint of the building
we would also be using soft boundaries
providing more homes for wildlife
for wildlife other projects have
recently been approved for large houses
which would cause more vehicles in the
village
and the same public transport issues
green lane itself
is private and has been maintained by
our family
for many years the committee report only
briefly touches upon the fact
that the existing structure is lawful we
believe greater emphasis
should have been given to the efficient
reuse of an
existing structure to provide a new home
we are happy to make a financial
contribution to rams
we feel that the neighboring properties
will not be affected
as it is only the internal detail that
will change
thank you chairman thank you very much
um
any other officers need to contribute
before we go on
okay so i'm going to put the
recommendation which is
that the application for the bungalow
green lane
be refused for the reasons detailed in
section 8 of this report um
i'm not going to look for a second or
it's too long and complicated and that's
on the table members and
councillor civil you called it in and
you are one of the ward members would
you like to start us off
you have the option uh yes
please chairman thank you okay
uh so this uh is an existing building
and there has been a bungalow on this
site since the 1920s and
previously it was occupied by the
applicant's grandparents
so in terms of their the urbanization
there isn't really a change here so
there isn't any urbanization
it is an existing building the offices
state
that there are facilities to this
property
that applies to every single house in
little tottenham
we have no no school we have no shop
we have no bus service so really in
terms of this application
that can't be seen as something relevant
one of the things in terms of the report
it's there is
it says there's no comment from the
parish council that's incorrect
the parish council did write in on this
and they do support this application
in terms of it being used for
alternative use
say for a business or something like
that that would increase the traffic
there would be more traffic
if this is a one-bedroom bungalow then
we're not going to see an increase in in
traffic it provides
necessary accommodation as the applicant
says
there is a shortage of this type of
property
within the valley within the village
it is well screened it's not visible
from
across fields there are already lots of
hedges and things around it
so again i can't see it having a
detrimental effect on the countryside
so when this application originally went
in this year
i didn't call it in because i thought it
was quite obvious that really this
should be
something that should be passed by the
council so when the applicant
reapplied i felt it necessary to call it
in
because this is really the sort of
development that we should be supporting
it's only 80 meters outside the
settlement boundary
it's already in existence it's audio
building
we are now putting a redundant building
back to good use
and that's all i'd like to say thank you
very much
uh councillor keys you are the other
ward member
um you could speak now or wait or
whatever i don't actually have anyone
else if you could put yourselves on the
chat please if you would like to speak
sorry council please
um i totally agree with councillor
siddal
i cannot see look
oh someone else speaking yeah i can't
see because i [ __ ] out
counsel of gone of this really because
this
as councillor said this is what we need
in these villages you know the place has
been there
you know as long as i ever remember and
i think it's correct council should have
called it in and i think
i would put an offer in that we go
against the officers
recommendation and i believe this should
be passed please
oh and i i'm happy to thicken the um
proposal by councillor keys thank you
very much
i i hear you but we do have to deal with
the recommendation
first so we'll do one and then and then
the other if necessary um
and i have councillor darren to speak
thank you chairman chairman i have total
sympathy with councillor
siddal and indeed keys on this but
unfortunately um a development boundary
is a development boundary
um and it if it falls outside be it by
80 meters or 800 meters
uh you know we we have to draw excuse
the pun we have to draw a line
somewhere um and you know i
i i take on board all of the comments um
and certainly there is very good reasons
why
um this this dwelling should be put back
into residential use but that's why
uh we endured the process of putting a
local development plan and we we can't
pick and choose i'm afraid
uh between um you know things that
comply with the ldp
and don't comply with the ldp so i shall
be
supporting the officer's recommendation
please
thank you um okay i have councillor
jarvis i also have councillor keys but i
think i might
let you round up at the end counselor
keys and chairman i believe
um mr lee wanted us to come in as well
oh
right absolutely uh let's have
councillor jarvis first then
please um thank you madam chairman yes
i just wanted to say that uh just
regarding counselor durham's
comments there i mean i'm aware that
this is outside of the ldp but i mean if
if it was simply that black and white
as councils we really wouldn't have much
much a role
in making these decisions so i think
actually i'd sort of counter that point
i think the whole point is that there
are
there are cases where we have to
consider the very fine points of
argument
and um you know and that when we if we
do go against officers that's
you know that that's when after we've
done that so i don't think it's that
black and white
on this particular case uh i think there
are some factors that were mentioned
which we're not supposed to take into
consideration they're not planning
considerations
or however sympathetic one might be
about family history etc
but purely looking at it from a sort of
planning point of view
um there's a prophecy there it's um and
the points that council civil made i
think quite eloquently
uh are correct uh it's uh the fact that
the parish uh
view isn't on the um officer's report i
think is disappointing if the parish
have
expressed the view and got it in on time
that should be there
i think something for you for the update
chairman okay thank you
that's always very useful to see um so i
think
um you know there are some good points
have been made and i think the point is
that uh you know we are we are supposed
to look at exceptions so purely from a
planning point of view
i think uh in this particular case in
terms of services that are available as
councillor silva said
that little tottenham i did live there
once um yeah
you could say that about almost any
property in little tottenham so i'm not
sure if that's
that relevant i think it's a fine case
but uh
bearing in mind exactly how close it is
to the boundary
and bearing in mind um the type of
property that's being built
um i think i would sort of probably find
in favor
i'm sure the officers when they looked
at it this is quite a finely balanced
case
and so i think i'd probably be minded to
uh find in favor of the application
thank you chad thank you um sorry
counselor keys i am going to
let you come back on everything at once
so i'm going to come to mr lee but
just before that i'm going to say fine
thank you with the with the family
matters you know we can't give a
personal permission
so that that's why the main reason why
we can't
we can't take um family considerations
into account i believe that's right
um mr lee anyway and i also have
councillor white
to follow mr lee chairman and council of
banford resources
sorry sorry thank you thank you i
thought it was just appropriate to come
back on a couple of points that
have been made um the debates moved on a
bit since they were first moved so i'll
try and accommodate them all in one sort
of
uh response um
as councillor durham said there are
planning policies
and there are boundaries for a reason um
legislation is clear that
plan applications should be determined
in the development plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise
um in relation to councillor jarvis's
point i don't think
actually this was a balanced decision at
all in offices minds
the site is outside second boundary we
have won
numerous appeals of on-site so actually
closer to segment boundaries than this
site
um there are not the day-to-day
facilities there are not um
close proximity to sustainable transport
etc in this site
we as an authority and all authorities
really
come to a decision about where we put
those seven boundaries for a reason
and quite often even though there may
not be facilities
within a village you create a segment
boundary to allow some growth and
development around those villages
that anything outside of that is
contrary to policy and you would need to
show
why this has particularly special
circumstances
many of the points that i've heard
debated so far
literally could be used to any existing
building outside a settlement boundary
in some relative closeness to
an existing settlement and i'd be very
worried about members taking such
an approach because they those decisions
like this are used against us and are
used to show an inconsistent
application of policy um the site has
been abandoned turns an applicant even
acknowledges this and
so any of the opportunities of that
there was a bungalow there was a
property there in the 20s
post have fallen away they aren't a
material consideration because
abandonment has happened
and so that alongside the personal
circumstances should not be given
any real weight in the determination as
plan application because they would be
flawed
um
and i think the the applicant submission
said about affordable housing this is
not affordable housing the planning
definition
this would be a personal dwelling for a
person
individual who wishes to live
in the district and it is no different
to any other development in that such so
members to go against the recommendation
they they they should
have to give us a reason to approve if
they do and but what i've heard so far
was
my official opinion is very generic and
does not talk to this application
it could be the exact same things words
that could be used and can be used
against us
for almost any application around the
district because it is just a structure
outside the segment boundary in this
instance thank you chairman
thank you right i have councillors
elaine white
durham and councillor keys if we could
do it in that order please unless anyone
objects violently
councillor bamford
thank you chair um
i've been looking through the report and
i can't really understand
um the application now this is a section
73a application so i wanted
for the purposes of the rest of the
committee for the offices to explain
what that actually means and it does say
for the refurbishment of a building and
the change of use
of associated land to residential
now that concerns me a little bit so i
just want to make sure
what we are being asked to consider here
and
i'm very wary of the fact of what um mr
lee has said that we must
abide by our policies in the ldp
um and we shouldn't get a motive about
this
you know we have policies in our ldp and
if we start saying no we're not going to
take any notice of them
um that's where we become it may become
a problem for this council
so um could i ask chairman through you
for an officer to just explain to the
committee exactly what
this application is thank you
thank you right i have mr lee ready to
go 73a
and thank germany the application is
partially retrospective in nature and
that's what section 73
relates to um as in some of the building
works have been taken and they're
looking to regularize that
um residential that is obviously
the site um the applicant is looking to
use this
area as dread uh
if um to be honest if we can get ms
haynes to
parkanes to show the whole site plan
that would be helpful are we actually
talking about
curtinage as opposed to further land for
further development um
that's that's a very very complex
question
okay uh percentage isn't set
definitively
um like that and so
as members will be able to see the site
plan
um that is what the applicant is
proposing to say would be
residential land that whole site um
and that's what the application is for
so that would be argued to be curcus
potentially in future arguments but if
members go against the recommendation
thank you
okay if it's sorry to come back if it's
not cursilage
what is it there can be garden land
curtains ah yeah so
it's all to do with the legal definition
of cartilage which is a very subjective
matter
so it yeah there's a slight variance and
differences so
that's the issue where i wouldn't want
to be making a definitive statement just
off the cuff on that point
okay i'll worry about that when we get
there councillor white please
[Music]
counselor white you're having trouble
with getting out of escaping the chat
function
madam chairman they didn't the order
didn't want to turn on
no just to say that you know i treat all
applications
they come to me and i treat every
application
separately um now the first application
from
a barn to a house that we had earlier
today had a totally different outlook
and a totally different planning history
and i honestly don't have a problem with
this the building's already there makes
no difference to me whether it's for
storage or whether it's for residential
it's there already
um the family are on site presumably
they're living somewhere on site
so i don't have a problem with it you
know we are creating one small house
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillor darum and then
we'll come back to councillor keys if
that's all right
well thank you chairman i don't wish to
bang the same old drum
uh but mr lee has put his argument
extremely succinctly
we mustn't lose fact of the we are
sitting as a planning committee
obliged to which is a quasi-judicial
procedure obliged to follow
uh our written and agreed policies
as agreed by the secretary of state now
we have to put aside
sentimental reasons or any other reasons
why
we go to the trouble of establishing uh
boundaries councillor bamford is
absolutely right the the implications
leading on in the future
uh are really quite grave and quite
considerable now i i
you know say again i have total sympathy
with this
but we we have to follow the rules
in fact we have to follow the law and
you know unless we're going to change
the boundaries and change our ldp
we really owe it to the district and
everybody
else to to follow it's not one rule for
one and one for another
i'm afraid the the ldp long
and hard fought is there for a reason
and that reason
is to guide the uh the um
granting or refusal of planning
applications and that's exactly what how
the officers have interpreted this
and and sorry as i am for the applicant
uh i i stick by what i say we have to
for the future and the well-being of
this authority follow the policies in
the ldp
thank you very much thank you i have mr
lee and i also have councillor siddal
so i'm conscious that councillor keys
has been waiting a long time
on the other hand councillor siddal
called it in so i'm going to go in
that order and let councillor syd will
be the final speaker but mr lee first
then council keys please
thank you chairman um just wanted to
come back on uh
councillor white's point um and yeah
she's right that each application
needs to be determined on its own basis
and
i accept that you know most members do
and i include councilwoman that you know
variances are taken into account
different applications but
what i would say is that the wording
that was put forward by herself at that
time and
seems to be the general consensus some
of the members that put forward is is
that there is a structure on site
and you know there is a building on site
and that
because the family are living on there
in a caravan at the moment that that
makes it acceptable
if that is the reason for approval any
future application
for building on site that someone put a
caravan in that we were then to look to
refuse
would be able to be used against us
because we are going against it
our own policy simply on the basis that
there is a currently a building there
and potentially there might be people
living it there
you need to be able to show what the
special circumstances for this
application
and everything that has been said so far
at the level of evidence so far at least
is
very generic in my professional opinion
and it
seems to apply to just because there's
some form of structure there already
you know the first application to go
back to that was not for
that was for demolition and the
structure for new dwelling but
previously using that barn because used
as an example
as a house had been refused by the
council and had been dismissed to appeal
that is the sort of consideration you
should be looking at as a point of
guidance as a material consideration is
what has the council done before what
have inspectors supported us with before
and that for example that actual
planning history on the first
application site
is a clear and precise example of how
members should be looking at
and not just members anybody this is the
decision maker whether it's an inspector
whether it's officers with its members
as the committee of how we should be
applying our policies
and weighing various material
considerations um
i understand personal circumstances are
emotive and sometimes you know
they do what make you want to support a
scheme but they are not material
situation
in this application and i think members
need to be conscious that any
application is determined that is not in
accordance with our development plan
will be used against us and unless we
can evidence why we have gone against
our development plan
it puts us a council in a very very
difficult position in the future
to be able to defend our ldp and at the
moment i'm not
hearing or seeing any specifics that way
in favor of this application
above something like the one we had
first thing with the planning history
thank you yeah okay thank you very much
counselor keys
finally got to i'm very very sorry i've
had to wait oh that's
fine um well i've heard what uh mr
parker bowles and i've heard what matt
lee said
and um i've heard what everybody else
has said here and i don't
understand the word i've never even
heard of what counselor durham said
quasi something i don't know what that
is
but this is this re is one of the main
or the only reason
i suppose one of the main reasons i came
on moldon district council
was for the planning side of it now
local knowledge now i've got
doesn't matter who lives there what
lives there i don't know i've got
nothing to do with that
family history or anything this is a
property
that is 80 meters outside the
the cartilage or the the ldp whatever we
want to say
this is there and i cannot and i still
stick by what i say
i think we should go against the
officers on this and i'm sure we can
come up
between us for a reason for this to be
passed
and really that's all i've got to say
i've got i cannot see a problem there's
a dwell in there
let's just make it back into a dwelling
and i'm sorry if i'm going against the
officers
i'm sorry if this may cause a load of
aggravation down
the garden path when we come to other
applications but i'm sure we've got to
take
each application on the merits that are
in front of us and the merits i see in
front of me
i personally cannot see a problem with
this application that's all i've got to
say i hope
councillor siddal's got something else
to say but i do sympathize with the
council
on this but this one in particular i
can't see a problem with
thank you okay thank you mr lee you're
obviously desperate
just for clarity there is not legally
dwelling on that site
there may one have been historically but
you it's been abandoned and that's what
the decision accounts has come to and
the applicant hasn't challenged that
so the applicant does accept that
historically there has been abandonment
um so i think members just need to be
clear of that
that this is not a case if it's a not
replacement of a dwelling or a
uh or you know there's previous
permission that you know something like
that as a material situation
this is there is not a dwelling on this
site legally and although there may have
been historically that has
come and gone and that needs to be clear
in members minds when they come to
termination's application because
otherwise
you could be misdirecting yourselves
thank you thank you councillor dharam
i'm going to
ask you to be very very quick please
because i need to get to councillors
i'll be extremely quick because i sit
here absolutely aghast chairman
uh uh nothing against councillor keys
per se but the length of time that he's
been on this authority to say he doesn't
understand the
quasi-judicial nature after all of the
planning training that we've
had um i i'm absolutely i'm absolutely
staggered and
it does not absolve us from the fact
that we have to follow
the rule of law and um well
i i honestly think that that by granting
this we will be opening a horrific door
um and we certainly should not thank you
right thank you now i know you're
desperate to come back council keys but
i'm not having a ding-dong across the
floor which is what this is going to
become very shortly uh council civil
please
thank you chairman thank you uh it it
it the officer says that this is uh
an abandoned building it may have been
abandoned but it was never knocked down
it's always been there it's always been
existence
uh over the last six months
that i have been on the the this year
especially
we have passed numerous applications
that are outside the settlement
boundaries
so there is a precedence for this there
are there are
other situations there's been some in
the great tottenham ward there's a barn
recently that was outside the settlement
boundary
that has just that was past planning
permission so there is a precedent for
this
so yeah it's not that we that this
yeah this building is going to be
magically appeared it's appeared it's
there it's been there
for a very long time and what we're
doing here
is returning an abandoned building
which is a residential building back
into use
and that's the sort of things that we
should be doing
okay thank you well um constitutionally
i have to put the
recommendation first and i don't know
which way that's going to go
um but we will have to have very very
specific reasons for approval
if we end up going that route
right members i i'm seeing hands out but
we're going to start going round and
round in circles
and i would like to put the
recommendation to the vote please
so miss bird can you take the roll call
this is we are starting on the original
recommendation
to refuse this application for the
reasons given
in the report ms burke thank you
chairman yes members
and vote against um the vote for refusal
as chairman just mentioned
if you could just indicate if you're for
against or abstaining please
starting with councillor bamford please
thank you thank you tara
i totally agree with everything that
councillor durham has said and i'm for
this recommendation thank you very much
councillor darren
at four counts of darwin i think that
was a four i think i saw a four
council down can you just confirm please
uh very definitely a four
thank you thank you very much thank you
guys
apologies thank you councillor jarvis
please
i think each on its merits i'm against
thank you councillor keys
definitely against councillor
sorry about that against thank you
council mrs thompson
for thank you councillor miss white
against because i treat every
application on its own merits
the results of that photo three in favor
four against and no one abstaining
thank you okay thank you so the
recommendation
falls um i need a proposal um i think
we haven't had a little discussion about
this but councillor siddal did you have
one at the ready
and then we'll need we need reasons for
for um approval um which
will you know satisfy the legal
requirements and therefore our officers
and then we'll need a second up once
we've thrashed through some of that
so okay so unless someone else has a
an oven ready one i don't have another
one
uh so i i would yeah my my
recommendation would be to
a approve this uh application
on the fact that uh it it uh
returns a building to use there
and that uh the conditions are that
we is approved with the existing
uh design and structure of the building
okay now what we're about to be told is
that
we need to address each of the proposed
reasons for refusal
um so it's about the rural location
so there is no there is no further
urbanization
uh the it is sustainable because
the unsustainable applies to every
single house
in little tottenham has already said um
and it it is already screened
from other properties by hedging and
trees
okay and we would in fact need
i'm going to have to take some
professional advice on this
um one of the reasons is the lack of a
completed legal agreements so
i would suggest we put in a condition
um the chairman
mr lee if members
i would recommend that it was delegated
subject to the completion of the section
106
agreement um so
that just like at the moment for all
applications that are
overturned or even applications normally
that have come to committee that are up
for approval for housing
have um they're delegated for the
completion the section 106 agreement
so that would be my recommendation
rather than it being determined at this
time
okay um any other conditions or any
other thing you want
obviously it's a new dwelling so my
suggestion would be that we should
delegate
uh conditions to officers just to er
just to make sure that
they're fully robust obviously we'd have
the plans and
times and all that but that would be my
suggestion on a more complex application
such as this and
with consultation with yourself as
chairman um
okay the only points i'd want to raise
is in the
argument towards the um
why this application should be allowed
is that
councillor siddal said the summary of it
is that as there is a building on site
there won't be any increase in
urbanization and that this is a
sustainable site
um that
person my professional advice is a very
very dangerous reason for approval that
could be used against us repeatedly
because
what we're saying is that um any
building that is there in theory can be
used for residential purposes without
causing any
urbanization which is something
obviously we've robustly defended and
won numerous appeals on
and also that this is outside of segment
boundary it's some 80 meters
and we've and it's 80 meters outside of
a
village that has no real resource real
services anyway
um and such an approach
but my advice is very dangerous because
there's nothing site specific about that
in the reasons for approval
it is very generic and
will be used against us that's all i'll
say you know um that would be my advice
to members
thank you i'll run some of that past
councillors i have got you councillor
jarvis um and i will get there right
councillor
siddal are you happy to incorporate
mr lee's suggestions as to conditions
and the 106
um in delegated in consultation with me
and i would actually add the award board
members to that
yeah and it is consultation not
agreement but you know i think we should
councillor white is also stating in the
chat that the reuse of an existing
building
uh from b one to eight oh yes i was
thinking
yes yes okay
got that for clarity
our policy does not support that and
we've won numerous appeals on
that whole argument that our policy
doesn't support that
and that um but also
the site so can you come up with it so
mr lee could you come up with that with
something that we could use
yeah rather than professional accounts
said oh no this is a scheme that is
contrary to policy a hundred percent
and i see no material considerations
that way in favor of the scheme
i'm more than happy to assist members
where i can but in this instance i can
find
nothing that supports the granting
planning approval for this scheme
it is a 100 country policy and i don't
see anything that weighs in its favor
all i see is it being country's policy
and being a very dangerous decision that
will be used against as an authority
time and again it's within your gift to
come to the decision that you want to
but i will provide you with my
professional advice as always um
and my professional advice is that i
cannot see a reason for improving this
application
but as always it's within your gift so
yeah i think we go because it's a change
change of use
to residential as as the the main the
main reason
right
so can i just say the whole point of
having planning committees
is so that members can as councillor
white is saying
that we can determine applications
that's that's the whole point of it
i understand that that most applications
are dedicated to officers
but the whole point of these sort of
things is that we as
as as members can make these decisions
and you know it's important that we are
able to do that
i will give away the jarvis
okay right members could you please not
use the chat function because
you know that's not available to members
of the public well
not without a freedom of information
request it isn't and i think you know
they have a right to see
what we are saying um
so councillor siddal your reasons for
approval
as you've just outlined have we got that
and we got that miss bird mr lee
that we're reusing an existing building
and
sorry just remind me please
council siddal sorry i didn't know
whether tara had been
writing down what we said a counselor
jarvis is also wanting to say yes
um yes but it's your proposal and okay
so i
i put forward your views and then
you may or may not accept amendments or
we may or may not vote on them
okay and miss bird have you got that yes
chairman
okay thank you i'll second it
right it seconded council jarvis please
thank you chairman um yeah i was i mean
i understand
cancer civil asking uh officer lee
whether he can assist us on this with
his expertise but i do understand
um though silly is clearly given his
view on that i mean i'm looking through
the reasons
for um officers recommending refusal and
that's where i sort of start
in terms of impact on residential
immunity i mean it seems to me in fact
there's a very low impact
in terms of access parking highway that
seems to be
you know one one resident seems to be a
very low impact
on parking or highway issues and in
terms of
the countryside and general landscaping
i mean i would have thought
uh councillor sales pointed out this has
a very low impact
on the sort of countryside look so i i i
don't know the exact
policies of celino's much better than me
but
that would be the sort of area that i'd
focus on that this is
has a very low impact on the character
and sort of countryside uh locally there
that would be i'm not sure if councillor
sorry if
officer lee can assist us in looking at
that avenue
in that area to find a reason for
approval
thank you jen mr lee
do you have any comment dude chairman um
as members know we've discussed this
many times the
reasons for approval need to
either talk to the reason's refusal or
that they override it such as you know
benefits outweigh the harm or things
such as that um
see the points that counselor job this
has made beginning bits absolutely being
post-compliant i don't think was he way
in favor of the decision because
those points were accepted by officers
but the latter points do
seem to talk more to this specific
application
as i said before you know the points
that have been raised so far
are very broad very generic and are not
specific
to this application enough in my opinion
professionally
so they couldn't be used against us um
that
there is a building there on site and
that is because i
think it's unbelievably dangerous for us
to say that this is
a sustainable site because it clearly
isn't
in any way sustainable and if members
are to
lay that down in a reason for approval
it's a very dangerous statement for the
council to make
um that's you know that thank you
i think we hear what you're saying right
i'm going to go back to councillor
siddal to see if he wants to
oh i've got councillor councillors aaron
sorry i didn't mean to
have a heavy side because it's you just
that we're going round and round and
round
please go ahead you're muted i believe
yes i've got my little second mute
button um yeah thank you
we are going round round circles we need
to to try and
find a solution uh to this
um i think you know the decision has
been made
fine um but the the reason for approval
needs to be worded in such a way that it
reduces
the likelihood of the opportunity that
this decision
can be seized upon um by
other applicants now i don't yeah i
don't
yes i don't know how we do that um
but uh yeah if it needs to be very site
specific
so that we we're reducing the
opportunity to create a precedent
um but i do feel the damage has been
done thank you
thank you right councillor
[Music]
oh michael howe mr johnson mr johnson
please go ahead
yes um just uh just a brief point um
obviously um as
most members know and mr lee's pointed
out
most decisions are made on the delegated
decision
we deal with many of these applications
we are increasingly being confronted
by applicants who are keeping a careful
eye on our five-year housing land supply
and making the arguments as to
or that their case may
be appropriate in certain respects and
would tip the balance
um because of what they may feel to be
the tenuous or otherwise nature of our
five-year housing land supply
this will increasingly become an
argument as we're going forward
now i see and i sign off many of these
decision
applications on on a daily basis and
i'm in a position to know how um
the development industry is reacting to
the decisions that we that we make
um this is a in particular these remote
meetings are probably even more public
than previously so therefore there will
be people
who have first-hand um awareness of the
nuances of the debate that we're making
um so and these again could become
arguments that where we're holding
uh the policy line as we do it could
then be open
open us to costs we talked about the
inconsistency of decisions
more and more repeatedly so these are
the concern that that that i would like
to raise at this point
um and as my colleague mr lee
council durham has has raised um
this could quite easily come back to
bite us thank you chairman
thank you um your hands up councillor
durham um
i'm afraid i'm not going to keep going
around this loop i am going to go
to even it might have even been a legacy
hand who knows
i'm going to go back to councillor civil
to see if he would like to
refine his reasons for approval at all
um he can see a way of making them site
specific
um unless well let's ask council siddhl
thank you chairman uh so my belief
is that this recommendation should be
approved
because it is returning an existing
residential
development building back into
residential
use uh there is no harm
in terms of the infrastructure and
the surrounding area because of the
nature of this
and there is no urbanization i know i
stick to what i said before
okay and you have all that this bird
uh yes tim and i do thank you very much
thank you very much and
you're still happy to cat to second
where we are with this councilor keys
100 okay thank you very much miss bird
the roll call please
so this time um after much
discussion we are looking at a proposal
to approve this
for the reasons just outlined by
councilman siddal
and with oh mr lee's back with
conditions
delegate the decision not even approval
be delegate decision
because we need the section 106 signed
first
okay happy with that mr bird
yes chairman thank you and so members um
but i'd just like to make sure you're
comfortable
thank you okay if you can
if much is coming is it just the
decision that the reasons for the
decision that are delegated or the
entire decision being delegated
it's the whole decision it's no
different to when we have a major
application for
and there's a section 106. it's the same
now if any one house would come in and
go through committee
the report doesn't members obviously
determine to a certain center that
it's actually delegated to officers
subject to the completion of sex 106.
it's in front of a better phrase it's a
technicality but it's just
how the wording needs to be for uh
otherwise
will that come back to the committee no
your delegate you're delegating the
decision
to us in consultation with
myself as chairman and the position
yes for example if we officers would
recommend this for approval the
recommendation would have been delegate
to the decision to officers to determine
subject to section 106.
this is basically just reflecting what
would have been the wording if it had
been an approval
so we can't we can't approve it
regardless of the 106.
but the 106 and the conditions are the
only things that could turn it down
we're not talking about
you turning out no it's not about us
overturning the account
okay just to make it clear in case
anyone thinks it could suddenly be
turned back into the
technicality of wording thank you but we
can't
i think you're saying we can't approve
it if there isn't
the 106 isn't agreed and we shouldn't be
otherwise if we actually approve it we
are saying we don't need the 106 and we
don't care
great thank you have we all got that
members so we are in fact
delegating yeah okay
roll call please miss bird
thank you chairman and members if you
could just indicate four against abstain
when i call your name please
starting with councillor bamford please
sorry i just want to clarify what we're
voting on we're voting on
we're voting on um
please read it now we've delegated
delegating that decision to
officers subject to the agreement of the
section 106
in consultation with the chairman and
the ward members that's my understanding
and these are the conditions of turning
it down
no conditions of approving conditions in
accordance with what
councillor said so we're voting if we
agree
with the conditions that councillor
siddal has put forward
is that what we're doing yes and it's
subject
mr johnson's got his hand out i'll come
to him but
we cannot just approve it now because we
don't have
i understand that chairman yeah i just
wanted to know what you're asking us to
vote on broadly speaking we're
we're we're approving in principle we're
agreeing with the proposal in principle
but the actual decision has to be
delegated to get everything else in line
mr johnson please uh no no just wanted
to point out that counselor signal
hasn't put forward the conditions
it's the reasons the principles behind
the principle behind
it the conditions would be pretty much
standard that we would put on any new
dwelling
and that we would confirm with the
chairman in terms of the legal agreement
there is in a sense a sort of legal
requirement for us to have a legal
agreement
this uh the legal agreement refers to a
designated european
site which um as an affected authority
we're bound to protect
hence the need for securing the legal
agreement thank you chairman
okay thank you sorry
sorry chairman i'm still not clear on
what i'm voting on
nor me okay i'm going to go back to
count
councillor miss bird poor miss bird um
could you please read out what you think
we're voting on
and chairman the reasons the reason that
councillor siddal gave
was yes and i'm just going back to it
sorry for approval
for approval
right sorry and then i'm against
right well hang on does anyone else need
it red i don't want to make this third
read it all out if we don't need it but
if anyone else would like to please
speak now
no it's okay thank you
so chairman if i if you're happy for me
to take the vote now
i am if the others are happy they know
what they're voting on which is
basically a delegated approval it's it's
yeah it's subject to the um necessary
legal agreements and conditions being
agreed
but it won't turn into something that
isn't an approval unless one of those
fails
thank you so starting our councillor
bamford please
[Music]
well i'm against the reasons okay
well that's the proposal so okay
that's the durham against
thank you councillor jarvis four
thank you councillors uh keys
four thank you councillor siddal
for councillor mrs thompson
against miss white
okay sharing the results that vote of
four in
favor three against and no abstentions
thank you
thank you so that um yeah
in substance that application is
approved but the delegated part
is the conditions and the 106 agreement
and that will be handled in consultation
with myself as chairman and the two
board members who are councillor settle
and councillor keys
so uh thank you everyone for that uh
last item is a non-event any other items
of business the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent there are
none
um so item nine is closure of the
meeting members thank you for your
contributions this afternoon
uh we thank you also to all officers
um everyone who's supported us in in the
background in it
um i'm gonna close the meeting at
whatever time you say it is miss bird i
think it's 14
23. um members now the meeting is closed
members are advised not to enter into
any further discussion on this forum and
please leave the meeting promptly so
thank you very much
everyone thank you chairman
you